oh [ __ ] has the bird flu chin has the
bird flu you know the road life's not
for you how you breaking down we get
that kangaroo flu you got a little cold
a little bit of cold yeah I don't know
oh I know it's gone here
koala your chlamydia in the face oh is
that why your eyes are seeping it is
seeping my eyes are crying everything
sleeping you don't feel good
lack of sleep to do that man the road
lighten up for you
now boy not but I still love it so you
know you know I love cookies but I gotta
stay away from Jack and now and I think
we should sing chinna thong chin here I
go yeah Nick get on the road again ring
and he carry those tickets come on Sage
hitching goes koala flu that's a great
song can you move that hand away thank
you
we all will sound succumbing you know we
know a few things there's gonna be crazy
late yeah I got a quick drink come in
with a big gallon of water yeah if he
drinks on the mic I'm gonna freak out
like all our fans did last time I got a
quiz for you I wanted to do a quiz I was
waiting gonna wait for will you don't
wanna wait for drugs oh no not to quit
okay top knowledge it's I'm gonna make a
sound and I want you to tell me what it
is all right you ready oh that's a real
sound now what is it Brewster think
Chris D'Elia bustled a nut no it's so
weird but it's in the other room
nope what is it anybody Surma here's a
hint
it's a sport and it just happened what
times well yes yeah the finals of the
hot the hot the finals of the job is
wrench open
please bring up highlights of the finals
of the French Open look at how similar
these girls look and then just listen to
what you would have to sit through for
three hours it's very interesting
the female a French Open and I was like
this is the most incredible thing yeah
there you go right there I like okay uh
they caught yeah they're dressed exactly
saying they look exactly the same and
just go I kind of jump ahead here and
just listen to this it's the most
bizarre thing oh my gosh I joined walk
out like I'll go and over the longer
rallies some of the longer hours are
like what yeah relax
oh I'll [ __ ] these two dude they all do
this I don't hear an adult do that the
dog goes in the dog's name is nice not
like this know that the girls go to my
lap but all day long that's too much man
bring that bring wrap up I want to hear
what he says he goes oh girls like it
apparently they think he sounds like
he's having sex sounds ah oh [ __ ]
alright I never thought of that
Oh a DA complains about Russell making
voice during his first I'll [ __ ] that
yeah
now put the put on his sounds tennis is
so into the highlights of him right now
yeah right [ __ ] these guys you want to
talk about hitting the ball hard like
[Applause]
can people see this tune cuz I'm bored
on sickness on they'll see look ah will
censor yes you have this pieces of it
alright not bad at all this stuff the
girl idea that girls are funny they good
get after all the crack man that was
weird
yeah really weird for sure I would leave
but because you're going because what
you do is doing uh and following the
ball like it all you hit and the ball
but when by the time she hits you're
done with your oh I would get so annoyed
that [ __ ] I would drive me [ __ ] hey
hey I was not screaming all the way
until I have to hit my [ __ ] ball ever
do that
what oh I would never do that but that
she have to [ __ ] Wow no you're not
dreaming it in Italy sway tying so no it
was that the tip that is one of them
wanted yeah I believe the one making the
most noise one the baby that's lies no
one sells anything she's just dominating
I malleable that is strange
yeah how's your night last night but you
guys raise money for your boy huh a date
raise money my boy hey Holly I'm not a
lot of people showed up but that's okay
a Tuesday night fundraisers and you hate
him it's do you hate your friend yeah it
would have been better to the 7-eleven
and ask for free money I agree and we
should have done that a different
would've been better go to Venice
Boardwalk and just have them sit there
in these little killers and I just
didn't have I wasn't involved in
planning it and I should have been I
don't know if you're the guy to plan it
either I would have to bet I'm at the
best planner who you actually taking
care of it yo rides on it you up rise
you to book the venue timing Ryan
Swisher everyone's really Tito you feel
promote
[ __ ] out yeah you know him he that so
goes immediate appease you know what you
do make sure it's for your fundraising
to you're gonna sell though yeah so
worse
don't worry how come there's even thing
to hey Brian was running helm they all
thought it was a different time he
posted hit home
uh yeah remember that time I go I cannot
be a good agent you go he's serious oh
my god why you got to be got him dude I
was uh a show last night the comedy
chaos Tripoli put it on the tatami store
we're time I'm up here at Kaiba store is
crazy it was a line I think I'm too nice
been doing it since 2001 or sad I
couldn't believe him on every single
night packed yeah every single and then
uh I mean there was Bert Kreischer Tom
Segura his wife yeah and then Russell
Peters on their case I love seeing
Russell because you know he always bust
my balls but Russell last time he made
like a you know a joke a fight joke or
something
because he went on after me and he did
that laugh ideas makes a joke my god
it's brutal man I said it I said
something to rogue oh my god [ __ ]
Russell kind of bust my balls man can't
hurt my feelings and rows like wool
that's what we do man yeah it's like a
lock of it so we use so I maybe Joe said
something to Russell Peters I don't know
we're in the bad guys what's up
sensitive Sally and I would sit in front
of it or not like I got a sensitive man
what's going on with you he's like bro I
was [ __ ] with you last I was really
making a joke videos you should be
worried if I say nothing exactly I like
you that's why I didn't like pop up come
on I know that this whole face of this
he's like yeah bunch me Mike that's I
don't I don't know what really the night
yes I get so silly I'm I'm gonna go so
if I'm gonna get up there and bust your
balls comedian in the world and the
nicest man in the world like Russell you
want to talk about money and fame did
not go to that guy's head and how he's
that same being him do it's not about
cars he's just bought he has more cars
and I mean his best car collection
oversea he likes fighting last night
who's flipping through these new cars he
got I was like oh my god
and he's like oh how sad how that little
shitty Porsche
we don't have anymore bro we Russell and
I got into a little he hugged me then I
goes a good underhooks dude there's a
good on those I'm whispering he goes
yeah see what I do this and I go no you
do not so I go not gonna keep you in -
we're trying to thing I'll never work on
me choking out all of a sudden turns in
a little bit of a wrestling match
tonight but see this is duck under and I
get under yeah and I duck under him and
were joking around and there's a guy
who's about 60 he's got a pug nose and
he goes try that on me I don't know he's
full of it you want to try to not make
me rooms goes this is outside I was like
I don't want to try that on you I don't
want to try to get something I don't
know you wanted to do it you got a your
nose he goes look at my nose any good
boys medical look like a harasser
definitely not going to try it only oh
yeah your hands look like they've been
broke I like it stuff a lot of it tight
rather we just stand there yeah that
kind of square fighters body you know
it's just like used to me not muscular I
was like nope if you're too confident
looking at me like I like Russell's
because the last thing I want I was
fighting them in the green red the
orange I cannot stand that man Russell
knows fighting better than most comics
and does not bother me at all he doesn't
joke about it didn't try in under hugs
we don't talk about any of that stuff
but while just all usually bring up Tim
like what do you think you less he's
like at school man and Russell's been
doing jiu-jitsu with Machado now I think
said four or five times a day for the
class like few months four times only
got five times a week yeah he's like I'm
trying to get my black belt
what a damn Sun like it's really doing
the damn thing good for him I don't know
good you're he's such a great guy
Russell just is a great person and sells
out this stadium didn't it yeah
international center no no he was at the
Staples Center in Los Angeles and sold
that out know him and Tom were time out
there
ticket sales how much they sell dates
were like oh my god yeah desert chillin
yeah cigars killing it so killing that
Segura can I get him on a [ __ ] hurricane
really do him and his wife be fun yes
irritate me last night and he look like
a GQ model I know he had a beard yet on
this dope Co he's a lot of way back to
different though yeah man was like with
so Shawn was it kind of sex up Tom
yeah like soul treat yeah they told
quiet noise like do you look hideous
yeah man we'll get him on the podcast
hey look at him on the peg cause why
bring him right now he just joined the
sexy club about two weeks ago let's
relax handsome guy to talk now he's
become you're right don't come home well
he's a good six feet you I was standing
next to him I was like pretty talk he's
talking about height he's just you know
comes here out of the beard now he's
trimmed down that handsome handsome hey
there was a disease eight if you bring
us was all those agents in the room and
Tom watch oh [ __ ] mister steal yo girl
look at Tom he's like yeah thanks man
I'm trying to don't like night for sure
dated hey chill yeah amber goes in front
of what no no no
I've lost just much his weight he was
just way [ __ ] sadder he's got that
sexy of like Jesus vertebra when I
walked into the greenroom Burt had his
shirt off for no reason
Burt come on oh did you end up going
there last night yeah I went to see you
I went to I went on for a night I didn't
know where the [ __ ] you were I went
backstage I know I was like where's
Brennan and it was all test planet
people out there I walked through and it
was like a you know yeah I went out
first so which is really the same as me
you know yeah I was out there's nice
hack crowd I could smell that crowd that
had a that crowd had a musky odor she
likes letters it smelled like flattered
it was it was smell like dummies dude
hey I it was a I don't know what it
smelled like I thought it smelled sick
and moist yeah and and and not like
girls yeah it was just dude no yeah and
I heard there were a lot of 10th planet
jujitsu guys in there I don't know you
know is that true yeah Oh cuz Eddie
Eddie Eddie got a new W Eddie did some
pop Eddie Bravo distance stand up yeah
all right I did
I didn't see much of it cuz I was
backstage to it I wish I would have saw
it I know you sorted like five minutes
he's up there for a while I don't know
how long but well yeah I didn't get to
see too much of it man that he was he
must have been test off and he has a
loyal following so I'm sure people came
you know yeah he's a good storyteller
funny but I didn't get to see much
because I was talking with Justin our
agent and then
backstage yeah so Justin that boy just
member the best hey will where's Sasso
oh man I mean he can't do it laughter
Lee as the minutes we'll sass way he's
if you said dinner plans with wailing
say seven o'clock show up nine okay
we're done yeah what do you deal with
yeah strange
we've been to dinner with him forever I
know you did the ten minute podcast when
he's been doing a movie and now he's
shooting a series called Loudermilk on
DirecTV dude I uh does that show on
Loudermilk too honey but uh there was a
there's a show on Showtime that Jim
Carrey produced
it's about stand-up yeah and it I'm not
area I'm dying up here and uh what's the
comic with red here he's on it he's
great
oh I'm oh I Andrew Santino he is you got
to get him on the potty he was on there
he's really good um Eric Griffin's on
there there's a bunch of comics yeah
it's a good show actually you know I'm
good I'm balls-deep on in Jim Kay I use
one of my ears so I watch for that first
episodes a little slow but it was good
it's on Showtime I just can't watch I
may be because I lived it for so long I
can't watch anybody clarify it you at
your job oh no no no matter what it's
not glorified at all no no no no not at
all no that's it's not really it's not
comedy and that's what Jim Carrey no I
know it so Jim Carrey was on Howard
Stern er say he's brilliant you signup
to Comedy Store you need at the store
and just going through everything in his
audition and I was trying to be a
regular and you went up there and he
bombed and then right after him was Bill
Maher and bill Mayer killed it and he's
like [ __ ] yeah and he said he'd even
he'd even stopped to look at him he just
knew he didn't get it so he ran off but
it was interesting because he goes you
know he's the best impressions in the
world for a long time he's like when the
very bad routable and he was doing it
and other comics give him [ __ ] like that
so gimmicky man like that's so lame so
he like got in his head he went away
from it so he said for forever like he
was like trying to find himself like
writing material stuff like that and
then he went back up at the store and
was doing regular Tyrael and who's the
owner of comes in the mint tea sure
Mitzi Mitzi called him was like what the
[ __ ] are you doing there yeah he's the
best and precious in the world yes why
would you not use as
tool so if any say start doing that for
like six months every night he had a new
routine and like he said you know
sometimes he'd bomb but a lot of times
it well with other comics he became like
this legend because that I dude every
night years something he never stopped
he's not doing the new never stopped
writing he never stopped working he
never stopped writing he was in his
office
yeah that's a good thing he takes yeah
and I hear you know I was saying he
never stopped when he was coming up I
know this because on MADtv
the creator's worked on in living color
with him that guy never stopped writing
he never stopped like he'd be with the
writers all day coming up with new
characters when he was doing stand-up he
was always doing something new when he
was on stage so he would perform and
then going right he was talking about
how on uh you know Easter and truly goes
how you doing alrighty that legs don't
let me finish that was a big cable of
the Comedy Store the Calvary was doing
time there all right ease it's quite
like he doesn't wake nobody good and it
was a way for any with it I heard I
heard some people like saying how back
in the day how Pet Detective was [ __ ]
and that he would say that I was like oh
boy you people are the biggest [ __ ] they
were they were working actors so that
was like you had the biggest [ __ ]
morons on the planet hey guys it was
genius they couldn't pull that all that
[ __ ] was erroneous what the class one of
the great is a cohort of this I got that
as one of my top performance MoMA into
hist one I don't get me a rainbow
amazing incredible it was so [ __ ] good
he's incredible and he was saying always
they were asking the Howard Stern was
like where you been and we've been doing
he's like I this is but this is what I
do
he goes I crazy hustle I take two years
off I crazy helpful take Indian he goes
those two years up so now you see me
doing this TV show he is we've actually
pitched up for years to be honest and
then he said he's gonna start doing more
movies now yeah they've been trying to
get a show about stand-up on the air for
as long as I've been doing stand-up you
know i bombed the first time I did
stand-up at The Comedy Store because the
Comedy Store
I had never so I was kind of a new comic
it was 19 this is guys this was 1997-98
and Rogin recommended me got me
as a showcase for mitzi and they give
you five minutes and I got up there and
I had my plan and I couldn't see the
audience it was dark
I had never performed back then it would
be completely pitch black and so you
were there and all you had was lights on
you and he doesn't Rumi and I didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do and I did my
stuff and nobody left
and yeah they good and I called the next
and ago you were highly recommended dad
but we'll see you in six months you know
thank you
it was it so the wait so for a while
like to be a regular at The Comedy Store
Mitsy would have to approve you right oh
yeah so did the second time audition I
met IMed sat with her and said you gotta
watch this kinda goes do your Israeli
pornstar character which ended up
becoming the character I did it in The
Hangover yeah but I take this chick you
know for me why did she like me for my
coke yeah my coke yeah he says I'd work
my coke well yes but no because my
coconut like American get later Michael
very big implants like I make very angry
Eddie and I did that [ __ ] I and when I
thought I take when I take that I make
like that I can settle in your specials
no it's based on a real guy I know I
know and you why don't you manage me I
need to and so did it but they did you
see the dish to wrote when I did that
character the bit seeing them they're
like yeah I got [ __ ] sign she was
like yes past so could only get past me
the back then then it I would do it I
would call my appendage go no I would
call my bells and I didn't past for the
first year and this is after I had work
I've worked done a lot more work than a
lot of con comics I was relegated to the
belly room and I would have to do the
belly room and so I was already kind of
an established actor or whatever it is
and I would imagine me yeah and a lot of
other stuff ah solute on you I done
series well again but net didn't matter
get up there in that [ __ ] belly room
and do the belly room for a year and
then I was invited down to the original
room it was really wild so it's just a
process I didn't have any problem with
it but um then it was great but then now
that she passed away has it worked now
is she I don't think she's passed away
she's she's passed no sorry
I'm sorry not all that she said he's not
yes she's not I didn't mean that she I
don't know how it goes now they probably
have a probably Adam and some other guys
are in vibrate but Mitchie with a
pioneer man Mitzi Mitzi was a treasure
and really new like she's the one who
told Carlos Mencia to change his name
his real name is Ned whole coldness or
hold some because he's German and Costa
Rican our dessert maker Adlon he's not
even Mexican food
she said change name to cousins here
when the Mexican pop fans when Mexican
people found out that he had been posing
Scruton it was it made him and it screw
them didn't know I was it was a big
problem oh yeah I mean also Rogen
exposing him for that whole situation
say he never got across his career and
never bounced oh you we have a month
actually Casey oh I'm just kidding
student [ __ ] have you he's good no I
talked to help funny would that be no
I've talked to Carlos Carlos what was it
like in stranded by rogue in it I also
had come front of everybody
yeah I have lots of thoughts on that and
I won't go into but on Charles Manson
yeah oh wow
well no one on when Joe was banned from
the Comedy Store I was he on whose band
because of that yeah because he wouldn't
apologize to and then he was dropped by
his agency so till that well drop like
Irish curse dropped him because he
wouldn't apologize to Carlos and Carlos
was the moneymaker at the time so I
wasn't making money he wasn't making the
money he didn't have a podcast how long
does this this was look it up I don't
know
mm and you know I don't know either way
curse drops Joe and The Comedy Store
drop them so what I did in solid clothes
Mencia was the big draw at the time yeah
he was huge
yeah and Joe was there every night and
Joe had never cast a check he'd never
cast a check from the Comedy Store and I
I ended up I basically said what year is
that four years ago now wasn't four
years ago it was way before that yeah no
no four years a long time either way I
remember I said to the comedy store I
said if you guys are going to banjo I
can't do your club anymore
you know I kind of I me and Ari Shaffir
I think were the guys who said we're not
going to do Comedy Store anymore in
solidarity with Joe right now this isn't
it Jen go go back it's easier to find
buzzer this blog about it
add but if you go to go that on state
well maybe that Joe robach on for four
years ago yeah no not that one I would
go to a jewelry marlin Cena on stage
video maybe it says it there yeah that
was one for four years ago 2013
definitely not this was this was god one
was this this was I mean a long time Joe
have me cookin yeah way before he had he
started doing Joe TV or something and no
man is good enough and you know we made
this I think it was a I think it was
Brian Redman and cut this together you
sure this is a really long four years I
don't Joe Lara is there's no way that
without him 7 2007 there you go okay so
that was 10 years ago
yeah 10,000 and I'm somebody important
enough that he had and the show by
saying Carlos Mencia that's who I am
we're broken [ __ ] what are you saying
look at roving standing up for what's
right yeah don't even know what night do
Rosen's doctor was asked to reach down
for just option to say you steal [ __ ] I
could say you feel [ __ ] then he still
already said is that what's our role in
the football oh he was doing it all the
time and Rosenthal tell you what I think
I think that every time you open your
mouth you talk about me I think that
you're secretly in love with me could
you can shut the [ __ ] about me that's
what I personally [ __ ] think he wrote
in with always anyway long story short
so so they get hurt but I'm surprised
comes toward a broken a mic okay well
well who Cambridge the comments were a
shout out to them but I got back then
you gotta remember to the comic store
was a real chaotic place like there was
no who they like it was no no dude there
were secret rooms guys to take girls up
there it was it was a [ __ ] it was not
there's a wild one
was gone Wild West brother wow wow
sounds all that was oh you have no idea
that was Meyer Lansky so does to die to
heaven I'm sorry
those 2007 even that yeah so this is at
the height of Carlos's powers when he
had them in see a show which has you it
was huge audience he was so huge so it
he would do this you know he would he
would you know I mean this was pretty
well documented in this dog did he take
dealing wills joke yeah including people
that opened for him yeah like wrote in
Rogan told me that the I'm not gonna say
the comics name but I was on saying
cardizem now when I don't get it man why
everyone doesn't like that guy goes what
would he do with like a newer comic like
you you can watch your set and because
you're not famous he's gonna steal your
[ __ ] make it his own use you don't have
to worry about that you are you know you
do to you but that's why yeah so that's
what no one bother me when bothered me
about the whole thing
well III like personally I didn't see
that so I don't want to say that but but
if Joe says it Joe's right a lot but and
a lot of people said it well Waldo so
here's the bottom we see that so do let
me know like all of them are sitting
having been there I was there many males
are on the show next week when I should
talk to great with him I've been there
many many times I was there many many
times when Klaus was there I was there
many many times when other comics would
be in the parking lot not wanting to go
on because they thought he would steal a
plenty of times when I that's what I saw
with my own eyes and experience and also
plenty of times when comics were
bad-mouthing Carlos right here was my
problem with the whole situation when
Joe stood up and he paid a price
professionally for it when when
essentially The Comedy Store banned him
because he wouldn't apologize and Gersh
banned him because he wouldn't apologize
to Carlos because I have the same agency
okay me and Ari were the only guys who
stood with Joe and stop doing the Comedy
Store and all the other comics who had
been the loudest and talking about it
you know a lot of them didn't and I was
like well if we're not going to kind of
stand with Joe hero what's right I don't
even
this is really bad that I'm even talking
about this I shouldn't still I'm not
trying to make myself look like anything
I'm just saying as a friend you know if
you have that much of a problem and I
never had it I never has never stolen
but I was I will do the cutting
so the comic store didn't let you and re
and oh no I I just I voluntarily said I
can't do it I can't it for me I was like
if you guys are going to if you guys are
going to banjo this way I can't do the
club if it doesn't feel right obvious my
credit is not right I'm surprised they
were really cool about it by the way I'm
surprised the times for banjo that's
crazy
so the Comedy Store wasn't in all the
Comedy Store basically said you got to
apologize and I might have been MIT's he
said you got to apologize to Carlos
because this isn't a place to air that
stuff okay and Joe said I'm not going to
apologize because we had been doing it
forever
yeah and so it was it was for him so Joe
didn't to the Comedy Store for five
years six six years yeah I'm surprised
cause Mencia didn't try and Sue Joe for
defamation there was a lot of stuff hey
because if you think you would if he was
at Walter I read ban made this video and
everybody saw it
including Comedy Central and including
agents you booked your calls Mencia you
would sue for defamation right what what
happened there well there wasn't there
you couldn't really sue for defamation
because you know he got up and accused
him of that somebody else was taking the
video somebody else posted the video so
for Joe he's allowed to accuse you of
this and on top of the fact that there
was evidence of it and there was a lot
there was a lot and a lot of
corroboration what happened it would
start to look up close and say what's he
doing these days still tours I get out
of here
yeah I wanted it kill uh yeah I got what
I don't know I don't want to I think
cross has played a very steep price for
this already yeah I hate no but I feel
we're asking about yeah happy alright
brother yeah beat you know post the blog
post that we saw for a second Joe wrote
that to Carlos about Carlos in 2005
telling people how he's stealing jokes
he didn't approach him on stage until
two years later oh you had another
that's how much wow Jesus well he I
think he brought him on stage as Carlos
men ste Leah well if you have to
introduce oh yeah and then the clouds
like what the egg so for you guys who
don't know cut the Comedy Store
when you do a set you bring on the next
car there's no emcee okay yeah but in in
Donora that's Anthony Rizzo room this
happened in your so they bring up Google
I've never seen him under steam around
but didn't say what he's doing yeah he's
still tours man he's still towards huzi
yes he still tours but you know it
interferes with let's check out his
website podcast and a 2017 tour schedule
I'm sure some yeah still he's still
doing the damn thing I'm sure I'm sure a
lot of people still like him I think he
learned a lesson man and I think he
deeply for ya hey I'm talking about a
guy who was a huge coal sincere act [ __ ]
you yeah Hugh yeah but it's like to me
like back then I'm thinking college
Mencia Jeff Foxworthy able the Cable Guy
Dane Cook yeah Dave Chappelle there's
like that group of just [ __ ] savages
Ralphie may like there's that group you
know there's like that that comedy group
in well I think also and you know I
think people who pay a price for this
you know there's this tendency to
completely dismiss them as human beings
and you hear this a lot and I I think
that a better way to go through life is
to realize that there are different
aspects of our personality sometimes the
bad aspect wins out and as well and
that's a dirty [ __ ] on hold on hold on
that that's a photocopy right so so in
other words we live in a time that I'll
tell you at this Oberer I don't know if
you saw this guy he was talking to
Arianna Huffington and he said he had to
resign so his career was [ __ ]
basically ruined or you know he was and
he said they said we should have more
women on the board of uber uber has been
going through some tough stuff and he
said the joking joking to Arianna
Huffington I believe this is a whole
story and he goes well it'll be more
female and also being more chatty or
more talk they'll be more talking it's
all he said that's not why result that
was a joke Voltaire of the uber ins
gnarly but I'm telling that was the
shocking sexist comment that was sort of
estrada broke the camel's back oh yeah
that is so long hold on it's not loose
it's [ __ ] because if you are if you
are going to hold people to what they
say now Carlos is a different story
what I'm trying to
say is that I think that people pay a
very steep price today in in social
media you say one thing in your whole
[ __ ] uber they're so close from the
idea the guy with the way he's running
uber and the environment he had of all
the employees is why he got fired okay
that this came out on social media
Kosmic see again get [ __ ] because of
social media yet [ __ ] to use stealing
giant great I know that I got the point
you're making when I'm making is this
the point I'm making all the way over
here the point I'm making no the point
I'm making is that people pay a price
for this the craziness on social media
yeah and the Internet is that you will
you can keep paying that price for the
rest of your [ __ ] life and I think
sometimes the crime the punishment
outweighs the crime that's all and I
think that is are stealing jokes you
made career off that you got you're
gonna pay a price
yes yeah that's a different story he's
still selling out I mean oh there he is
what are you drunk rat man forty minutes
what's up brother and you get the jug of
water as usual hey look hey look are you
drunk or what man are you are you high
bro no yeah you got to do whatever you
want now we're gonna pause cuz I'm gonna
go piss cause I got a going with your
brother hands up to see you man I'm
gonna stand up ahh bra cause that's an
awkward kitchen honey you know that ah
hey you're [ __ ] huge man oh and
gentlemen the white Samoan will sasso
the white Samoan is an earring I like
polar bear the white polar bear you
really take a little pause yeah why
wouldn't you want to do I'll do whatever
you want
alright [ __ ] alright I'll beat on this
man
I'm not big Tony I'm just big time here
so that's not will they keep it going
let's go on okay
so alright so hi welcome back to the man
the fighter on the kid my name is Will
Sasso I'm a philanthropist actor new
actor shamanic - [ __ ] all that stuff
that's not what it's not what I do you
know that's just what I do
you know I'm saying anyway I'm a really
good friend of Brian and Brendan's if
you've been listening to show a long
time then you might know me you know
what I mean
so it's okay that I take over for a
little while they hate it when I bring
this big bottle and move the mic with my
face
I also have a podcast it doesn't matter
and you know the guys asked me to come
over today and be on the show I got no
problems doing that I have no problem
talking to their audience and it's
always fun to come here look at all this
stupid [ __ ] on the walls when I say I
have a podcast I mean that you know just
sort of exists to me in the space and
the pod space you know it's up there in
the internet it's called ten minute
podcast but here you know Brian and
Brennan have done something very
different you know they're they're
they've they are the fighter in the kid
you know when I say I oh I'm not an
actor I'm a you know I'm the person I'm
a philanthropist I got other things
going on you know I'm uh that that's
what I am they are this podcast I mean
look look at the [ __ ] they got like
everything is they got chairs and they
got an office my stuff's just in the
bottom of my house anyway did they
already cover all this stuff hey guys
here's the copy to run Naomi undies oh
no we can't do that okay no you can't do
that because that's those are sponsors
yes right now if you upset the sponsors
then there'll be a problem maybe I'm not
sparkly right I'm not sponsored by me
undies but I have underwear on uh one
time Brian was playing volleyball with
Brendan
and me and a few other friends just
south of the pier hold on I'm Thomas
mark and Brian took his took his pants
off was no no I'm talking about we were
playing volleyball and you took your
pants off and what remember what you did
when you put your dink in the sand I
relaxed it yeah get out no we why do you
push your will around this because he's
an ass ah-ha keep your saying I actually
might be right
yeah there yeah all right but don't spaz
out all right
[ __ ] do a good job um okay all right
man but don't get all physical thing I'm
gonna get fit adjust myself rock you up
a little bit rough young which it did
that's Oh what are you doing besides
enough all night and drinking tequila
you're our [ __ ] mess sounds like a
good time though I don't drink
yeah take your sunglasses off no leave
off instant I know your eyes Achilles
where have you been man you did did he I
was on the road honor oh I am NOT a
waiter water the jug of water tries to
be great always has the jug allowance
watered you drink a debt and why are you
sweating I don't know it's [ __ ] hot
out there I'm wearing two shirts and a
hat I'm a big guy I have a slight salt
imbalance coupled with a possible
thyroid problem with the you guys leave
me in here I was talking about your
[ __ ] set if you can call something a
set yeah it's in a you know a room that
the fourth kid gets in a fit big enough
for a twin size bed hey don't be digital
to our studio I'm not being
disrespectful I'm just saying you got
all sorts of cool [ __ ] yeah all right
you I did your 10-minute podcast yeah
destroyed with oh yeah it's by the way I
am it did the 10 minute podcast yeah
thank you so much for sitting in and I
was amazing but here's the thing well
you you still in that dumb basement yeah
in my house changed a [ __ ] thing well
I got a drive for three hours to get
here from Los Feliz if your voice down
and to do my podcast all you got to do
is go downstairs so here's the
although this room is way bigger than
the room we do the 10 minute podcast in
mine could use a lick of paint I feel
happy yeah I'm happy to be here I'm
always happy to speak to your audience
Tung city yourself at home consider
yourself one of the family we've taken
to you so strong I ask Claire well we're
going to get along very good very good
done and we're Hong City so Annie is
that from Annie no it's all over Twitter
right Oh God to yourself well in cousin
itself part of the furniture
oh you haven't got much to smell who
cares
what I've only got yeah all right good
so um okay but a baby really I'm gonna
hey man how was Australia it was nice
yeah yeah you doesn't know I've never
been down there ostomy hourglass wow
yeah we're right what do they call they
call lobsters bugs out there yeah they
do while they're in the bedroom there
they are
shut the [ __ ] up about animals I'm just
talking about Australian well and he
would say oh happy to go really why do
we call them bugs cuz they yeah I'm tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch it Tom oh dude what's going to
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing oh [ __ ]
did you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
good night I'll shut up Brian will you
finally speak of a [ __ ]
well well kind of well I say what I said
to [ __ ] crystalline hello serious man
who who's that listen if you feelin
froggy
we got head and leap all right now
look at the trouble can you be in
disrespect darling well there's habla he
trouble here okay drop here let me tell
you something what you remember a while
back
speaking Tim in a podcast thank you for
sitting in for Tommy Blodgett and
remember the time that you wrote a
letter to Chad Kultgen
because years ago we're working on a
project in Chad and I was training in
mixed martial arts
yes and Muay Thai yes let's be let's be
clear I was a guy in his you know mid
30s training in my time
yeah just kind of rolling around you
know just having my trainer Harold
Dimond you know yeah you're all diamonds
and you as Karen would take the value of
someone else though you would kick the
bag and tonight Harold diamond would say
that kick right there would split
somebody's liver yeah yeah yeah sure
good times brought thing about it is I
was just like a big you know just a big
sloppy fat dude in the gym don't be that
mean yourself and I'm not I'm a
pragmatist I'm a realist okay and you
wrote a letter to chat to chat said if I
had a year term or be able to put will
really choke and you explain to him the
difference between a dog and a bear you
wrote him an email
si well he wrote your trainer he wrote I
wrote my doggie Elton is a writer and is
about five seven and only five ten he's
not 510 yeah it's a ridiculous thing to
say no I'm I'm I Drive 11 I'm going with
will on this because you're always five
every time seven without question
there's no no yeah probably about five
ten okay let's just be like what live
nine he's five nine one 71-65 okay I put
on a 185 now your stop just wall I'm
sick blogs around you if you saw me do
madman and a regular guy and not a not a
regular got baseball thank you yeah he
[ __ ] owl ate some baseball hell of a
baseball player is a sick dude he
placing historical placement and he
plays baseball up until last year and he
said I think I could take well if I
train and I had to explain to him that
that just wouldn't happen
you wrote him in the essay I wrote
chatez ain't nothing else to do he wrote
him a long essay called out the organ
the bear argument bear that he posted on
his website because it was it was well
received it
very the guy was dead serious study
could be with ya dad is always serious I
had take a minute I hadn't met this guy
no I don't believe so he's a he's
fantastic writer producer and he his
contention was he wasn't saying this
would definitely be what happened but he
said he goes I think if I had a year to
Train and I put on what's up something
ridiculous he said like 20 pounds of
munchies in Christ against asteroid's
yeah he's but he's just yeah and he'd
never had any training so he's just a
big fight fan you know he's a huge MMA
fan and he also said he could you could
potentially beat a whale in a fight he's
older he's holier I think yes
well if I got if I got my fingers deep
in a tie I feel like it would be like ah
and then I would kind of technically win
the fight so his point was that he could
take willed like years I had to explain
am that will is if will was motivated
and strong will would will very hard to
hurt where guys never really pawned here
you know Clough and I said also that
we'll wanted to he could [ __ ] and that
was a hard thing for a prideful man but
you need to understand the way the
universe works a dog ain't beat beating
the bear a silverback ain't here in a
peep out of a chimp either yeah not a
peep and did it get through to this guy
yeah yeah Chad said uh you know who I'm
telling you very realistic oh my god and
I think I didn't think I like to win but
a lot of this stuff I'll save it up read
it 50 times to dub Davidoff couldn't
believe that his friend Bryan Callen
would take this much time to break down
yeah there's two men let us say but one
of the things I would say about you is
that when guys when guys who are regular
guys who played some sports and have
some pride will say well how would you
do against Brendan I go are you asking
really how you would do against Brendan
and then I go yeah well you and I go I
go what you need to know about him and
it's not it's a hard thing for you to
hear as a man is that if Brendan wanted
to [ __ ] you he could [ __ ] you it was
that so we're not talking about beating
us all but no but that's all very
important thing to understand that
there's gonna be somebody else and then
somebody who can truly impose their will
on you well it's [ __ ] look and I
appreciate that you're a bottom line guy
and when someone is coming to you with a
you know question they're sort of
beating around the bush
well how would you do this but you you
zone right and you go I know what you
want to know you want to know if you
could what you would do is appreciate
and they all go and then you just cut
the conversation off with he'll [ __ ] you
so that they stop saying oh no matter
here look it's abrasive a little trick
somebody here's here's where here's
where this is story that I got this from
from an interesting experience I'm in
theater School in New York City you've
never been to New York shut up
you ain't never been right in here just
ready
no worse exhausting I know that's J rsj
job no come on come on let me just get
through so you've never been on a
[ __ ] crew you why is that so Quinn
has no really I gotta hear sorry I have
shut up I have a friend you never get to
know Mike Cruz to do your gives a [ __ ]
no but he goes on cruises God nobody
wants to hold big booking do it what the
[ __ ] is the matter with private stop
every [ __ ] story
remember on the truck I did when I was a
kid I wasn't trying at a nursery read
what [ __ ] late eighties early night I
don't give I was [ __ ] ahead to haul
her glance around you don't know how to
dry but ride a shitty Datsun trouble
would you let me just some people here
in New York in ballet school I'm in I'm
in theater school and there was a guy
who was a giant dude he [ __ ] who who is
no he was he happen to have been a
professional ballet dancer and had never
fought but he was I you know me I have
I've spent enough time and looking at
men and doing sports others like
wrestling whether it was I gonna wear I
know I can see that how much it is
lovely to see if you were to fight
somebody how much that would be to
manage if they were motivated to fight
and if your array like I knew the guy
was built like me but not really had
never really done any sports he was
built like me but he lifted weight and
he was a little he would do yet he would
do bench press and he would do pulldown
yeah each brother so they did regular
guy but never done any sports
and wasn't so athletic but he was kind
of amply sized he was a little bigger
than me maybe but whatever and he
decided that because this guy they were
doing a scene now in theater school and
I don't know if you've ever had this
experience but in theater school scenes
can get very charged and emotional
sometimes as they say you're making
believe but your body doesn't forget
that you're making believe in your body
takes over and they only do charge to
work oh no I would define well that way
all right what's like working will
charged yeah yeah I only do intense work
go fight her kid through that time was I
said what they said how was it with will
out settlement charged trashed intense
yeah
you ever lick a nine-volt no yeah just a
hatch a nine-volt to you has it burned
you two in college dude car battery and
keep it there for a human that's not the
funnest anyway sorry going okay so this
guy what they're doing a scene and and
it's an improv scene and this guy starts
to get macho with the big ballet dancer
who was not gay but very kind of like
you know he would wear who took a didn't
know he yeah maybe you know and I was
watching this and he started to shove
the ballet dancer and the ballet dancer
who was big and Germanic and just you
know just all raw bones and had been
dancing his whole life goes hit let's
just say the guy's name is Chris he was
Chris stop Chris stop just broke the
scene into the risky I Chris kept
getting in his face and pushing him
playing the role yeah but he was he was
trying to alpha dog I mean the burly
real in front of everybody and he was
doing it in a sloppy kind of uncool
aggressive way and he kept going Chris
I said stop and finally he tried to put
the ballet dancer in a headlock and I
actually came at him and the ballet
dancer flipped there was a switch jail
on his face he switched and he went the
way a big brother does to a little
brother he grabbed him around the body
brought him to the ground and got on top
of him
and just got on top of him and
God is like almost like an a half guard
kind of got his leg and pushed him down
and held him down and then put his arms
under his neck and just squeezed him
into a spot into his chest and said and
the guys
kriste are going Galloway Gabby he's
like calm down calm down and God and he
hold him until Chris started to cry
he'd never been he'd never been in that
situation he'd never been physically
imposed upon by another man if also guys
walk around like that or try like WNC
Wow now that well then that would have
been also yes Olivia hi the thing to
just go well charge
well you're got her locked in right
you've got a really this was a kid had
never been in theater school this is all
new emotional work a lot of boys grow up
especially in this country where emotion
and all that [ __ ] is not comfortable
we're being imposed upon if you've never
done sports is really new like you never
done a sport never been labeled level in
the plains this recomm well and somebody
shows you that and you're in your 20s
again you've never had that Clarion's
you hold it for no brothers assist yeah
very weird - not yet that going if
you're you know I mean just if you
played contact sports of [ __ ] starts
happening literally right away but in
there I don't ever done that but you
know you don't have a brother who in my
case used to say meatball boy and hold
my nose to my to my knees yeah
he's nine years older than me and he
would grab me under the knee about that
ball boy ball boy and I'm like you need
that stuff - yeah four five six ten
years old ha
chubby ten year old still going meatball
boy yeah how about the time that his his
body with an island like some people
have that body with her like no Island
Bob nobody's ever done that to them yeah
so that's another boy that's a crisis at
23 and somebody's holding you down you
can't breathe in front everybody and you
literally can't move from under a man
yeah he so I never forgot this my
teacher who is this wonderful big gay
man with the biggest mustache in the
world who is still one of my heroes and
he changed my life and he looked at him
and he goes Chris as he was crying they
stopped it he could Chris what happened
here
huh he goes forth average nap you know
Chris what happened besides the fact
that you almost got [ __ ] Wow said that
and that was I never forgot a reality
check it was a reality check and there
are there are those reality checks in
life in general you ever see somebody
who's never had to work out super hard
and they just so out of breath it's like
what did Vince Lombardi say fatigue
makes cowards of us all yeah first time
you've ever been pushed to that degree
I'm sure as an athlete when you guys put
yourself to that or football or whether
it would MMA I'm sure you saw guys break
whoo oh yeah right everyone has a
because they were in a place where they
didn't know how to get out of it it's
just tough work you're gonna have
breaking point you know the giant German
actor that does ballet is not breaking
anyone I know but yeah yeah your story
kind of you know yeah I mean you can
tell me your story you know I'll listen
your story hello of this respectful Club
Ryan hey man whatever in that stuff but
here's what you're making an absolutely
great point and it all comes back to the
dog and the bear the silverback in the
chimp whatever you want to say and this
is why when you are a guy who you know
you and you're what so I have 175 11
careful how you characterize doesn't
matter because they make me mad boxing
and [ __ ] and the reason it made me laugh
from the bottom of my gut is that if you
ever step to me give a [ __ ] if we're in
the theater class yeah I'll give a [ __ ]
if we're on a cruise and you're careful
where we are especially respectful I'll
fold you a full jet no yes
and I'll toss you on top of the tallest
building I've seen oh no I'll have a
look around I'll laugh at that there's a
two-story building the seams here what
are we on the third floor here yeah so
this has got three floors this place yet
all the all the places in this whole
complex very pretty cool stuff yeah
there's lots of great [ __ ] outside
there's as I was walking in I saw a food
truck yeah everyone was ordering stuff
yeah and careful now looks like it's a
good thing yeah if we were out there and
I was in line and I was like yeah hi
chicken Caesar no peanuts and then you
walked up and you shoved me out of the
way and you look through food store cool
and I would just fold you and turn you
around and I would start spit and I go
there in it and it's like oh there's one
and
three stories up [ __ ] you he'd wake up
travel ration for the room just crumpled
up against an air conditioning unit torn
what the [ __ ] a pecan figure you you'll
get gravel rash what's up so be so the
guys out there will be up there tar in
the gravel this are hot mop and you'll
go watch yeah you got a little you're
hot it's hot up there you got some tar I
guess tomorrow you got gravel ration
probably it has little bony in my pants
yeah a little [ __ ] a little [ __ ] in your
pants and listen I appreciate what
you're saying and I get it I'm not a
regular guy I got a lot of tricks here
on that trick I'm just a no biggest chat
I'll get will the weird again I've been
sitting down the punches lately doing a
lot of sparring a measuring distance
who's the guy's I say you can all
unequivocally I always give you props
and I say that goes to a fight an
organized fight and I would love to see
it happen maybe we can set up some sort
of charity I know what's happening
Brian's taking that [ __ ] dudes head
off who's that who I say that about CM
Punk
okay I don't know Brooks yes I always
say that Brian at 50 years old
yeah you'd be able to [ __ ] you'd be
able to give CM Punk a false sense of
security
he'd come at you and then you throw one
of them box and Bob spin kicks like you
do on Instagram yeah get him into that
gravel rack you get them gravel round
table grass you know get them in the hot
mops and the blacktop now he's going to
fight again huh probably come on that'll
be fun it's a nice compliment now be
careful so what I'm going to say is I'll
kick his ass and your [ __ ] man I'll
just go both of them will you hold up
hey I'll [ __ ] both up listen I'm all
oh hey how about this yeah yeah [ __ ]
quote me I'll only fight CM Punk if I'm
fighting Bryan Callen at the same time
what do you mean because I want to show
people the difference I'm just a big
what if Brennan and you as I walk in
here yeah here he is the right thing
albino Samoan the game polar bear - you
wonder the polar bear do there's a polar
bear do any because you do any mixed
martial arts or ballet now you do any
lifting wax I know what does he do he
drag walruses up on - that's right he
lives he hunts and he lives yeah and
that's what I do I
Conte and I live yeah and at 8:00 he is
it's a regular day on the ice for me to
drag CM Punk and Bryan up out of the
water onto my iceberg and just pools and
pools of blood pools of blood regularly
on that regular day on the ice I've got
to eat other day on there what am I
going to let Brian go because I'm eating
CM Punk no yo chill Bobo Danya
well then I'll fight CM Punk so long as
I'm fighting Brian town handicap match
okay that's who won won and you guys got
to wear matching [ __ ] like you're aware
[ __ ] tag to your anywhere don't tell
me what to [ __ ] wearing and CM Punk
know hey will what was the tag team
where they had the shoulder peasant
spikes on both road warriors yeah yes
yeah yeah road warrior animal and road
where what I want oh what a rush
I'm where what I want all we need you to
wear yeah no you guys yeah you guys were
to wear but I want you to wear like yeah
you guys are going to wear spiky
shoulder pads but I want the spikes dick
no I want you guys in matching like
killer beez outfits like B Brian Blair
and joke around on that CM Punk used to
be a professional wrestler and that's
what I want you guys can't move around
just it's just no it's just a single you
know it's just little too short that's
I'm a striped with the killer B's just
like B's like black and yellow and then
you know some cute knee pads and then
wings maybe at the back there wings if
you want whatever some be wings yet yeah
just for the entrance right and then and
then you guys get the ring and that's
the only way I'll fight CM Punk alright
okay did he fight again ah that's the
room William alright good like you know
big huge slope and shaved albino Samoan
polar bear okay
now let me ask you something I don't
give a [ __ ] how much boxing you alright
how about it did you do some boxing oh
cool hey well does it when you're on
you've been working a ton done set does
anyone like a so does anyone talk about
fighting or [ __ ] with you ever
they're mean never no no no I'm a I'm a
nice gentle person my mom no but your I
am dudes are people like the hand
never kind of a quiet I would like up
see about the years
no nobody costs me about the year the
question it's not a question yeah you
put your back here and dream of smacking
away whatever I can apologize I'll do
that no that never happened wake up and
dance around Union over your face
no lightning fine no that's lightning
fast jabs yeah let's get in the parking
lot after that I'll bring the [ __ ]
camera which [ __ ] let's get it going
I would actually get on the roof where
it's mad you mind you might take my
shirt off outside and inside of your
[ __ ] knees whoa
once you have a look at my news those
are big knees I hurt my foot yeah that
might hurt look at besides that bull
heart for a cat the giant yeah the
biggest cats I've ever seen right that's
it yeah I mean you're a professional
fighter I only used to kick those knees
I uh yeah you could get you know like
weird hey you know it's weird guys I
never think about that yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] yeah and also you know who else
it the the yet people on set are always
very very kind I exist in a very kind
behind sphere I don't have your kindness
is the is the conversion Tina Hendrix's
yeah we just did a movie screening her
up she's so hot Christina Henry's doing
it's called the burning woman it'll be
out later you know are you the one
native Tyler no I'm not the burning mana
at CNM I never played a woman yes I'm
mad tv several times she's the one from
one of the most beautiful to shoot she
then I'm mad man a real eyebrow neo yeah
and uh today yeah Cena and I are married
it's really one of the most beautiful in
the world and we have kids
and yeah it's a it's a cute Sam cool
person well she's a she's the [ __ ] her
and Sienna Miller were wonderful yeah
Miller - yeah yeah it's a great one
doing that all dying pieces and her do
you play some guy who gets kicked in the
face and then that's the enemy no no i
don't know i don't i play christina
hendricks husband we have a family and
then sienna miller is her sister my
sister-in-law bring up the miller
formation hey I'm will did you get to
kiss our booth it is why I read in the
movie yeah so you were kissing we have
seven love scenes oh my god man we don't
have seven you guys were making that
well Miller's got something to say as
you well my shirt
[ __ ] hat off
wizzy Wisman I hear uh Ryoga bucket have
amassed over her
yes yeah no Miller is a Oh Lord
Matt what you were dealing with on a
daily basis she they were these are my
pals Micah denied you're still afraid of
the old you still afraid of girls huh
girls on the clam up around you go I'm
not [ __ ] bout we're hanging out we're
making a nice movie American I know
you're I am American I'm an American
consider or not if i yeah yeah we're
good race - I'm not a date
take that back walk around you walk
around set all day and you can't you're
not losing your [ __ ] huh I'm not losing
my your there your your friends on your
there pal yeah yeah Indiana an alien
with no CNN your father there right now
higher movie a bit those are some
beautiful very very Lord good Lord
they're beautiful they both hitched up
yeah they got they got guys yeah they
got guys who are there guys beautiful
successful but who are the guys that got
them oh geez look at this Sienna Miller
dating oh that's right he just read
Jesus identity that's her boyfriend yeah
yes I don't love when I see those girls
but normal oh he's 50 be doctor you oh
yeah he's a film director you don't get
this birthplace New York City this guy's
been in New York take a cruise all right
I got to get into film directing and
there's some big movies too all right
well no Christina Hendricks is with that
guy that uh he looks like a Jeffrey
what's he do he's an actor
are you jealous of them well why are you
jealous of them no no I'm not jealous um
I want a some beef between Union no
don't you have time
yeah Jeff Jeff our end wonderful guy
very funny bro if ever someone pulled
out see when I come we call that out
kicking your cover I'll kick in your
coverage right thanks I think you're
right I think how long was good thing as
fair to say you are a I see her thumb up
and then there's this whole yeah on days
I listen I'm sure he got fond he done
yep that [ __ ] looks like she
carries her burn he's got a look man
they know they are very they're very
busy and we you're already not equal no
not yet I've been around them both
they're both wonderful people and it's a
very adorable of functional marriage
they're very much Anna I'm not steal
don't talk that way my pal sure is great
I'm sure he's gay where's the premier so
let's slide on in
when does premier big meadow know it's
got a vibe on us
okay well we'll probably if you want to
see Brendan bully a guy out of the way
he's gonna come up whisper and go I will
[ __ ] kick your hips I know I will do
that no I won't do that say I won't do
any of that I'm just gonna say what's up
to her and just pretend he's not your
room over not only illumise campaign
he's here I just know where you wear
that are you gonna be like moon suede
Jack I'm left to see what she's working
with I don't I don't wear red she has
red here at my class because yeah you
don't out you know I tried out door you
wanted out you're gonna be like good for
that dude are you going to be like a
like a like a villain in like a 1950s
movie who's like wants to dance with the
woman and he just goes up taps on the
guy and just goes beat it pal because
out
take a hike pal take a hike more like
Pepe LePew lights out in this case
anyway so we were on this set and I got
number house on this set I don't coffee
powder everyone bothers me you call
those you all my pal never be friends
with a girl like that never why not we
because all I'd be doing is like a tiger
at the top running there is only one
style hanging out a few friends Oh
having dinner
yeah at your house nope uh-huh or else
those directors
okay is that in LA yeah well what date
is that pretty soon what criteria
I see Leland I hear all right wait hey
whoa hey oh they have their friends you
invite your friends yeah okay but we're
all friends at all well now I don't know
we're boys okay I understand you guys
can I bring one person well I kind of
its a plus-one type thing yes you can't
have too many people rake out your
backed out the butter and squeeze me on
it no I don't want to go got it why
don't we go beyond it
oh hey I'm with will on this you want to
go to like Souplantation with us maybe
the next day [ __ ] you bro
an early bronze on my shoulders and hips
I want to go to squeeze hey hey hey do
you like chicken and Alex I would go to
tender dreams eat it oh that'd be fun I
can early driver I will tell you about
the party was yeah we could do they ran
it hard rather so that's my brother I
will run it be the kitchen like today
brothers yeah what what the quest kids
be no other little days squeeze me
lemonade will go to lemonade on a bikini
yeah and I have a kid on me I won't make
a lot of noise yeah yeah that rabbit the
the radish salad with the they got the
little pieces of poke yeah that'd be
good free well me with my new friends
you guys let me know something you want
to know something
where's she from oh come on guys are
Iowa Idaho 11i Idaho you know our
district my new friend like that that's
right that's right
Bremen's in an Irish I can have I
respect tournament and you know what
I'll see you Friday night I take pride
in being good buddies with stunning
women and I don't trust you is I know
you don't know you don't ever judge me
you know they say something yeah they
put your friends on real good yeah why I
know you know what I show up in the
friend zone can i I'm a friendly got any
errands rather can I know much so when I
show up on set now you know that I'm you
know I'm around what am i I'm like six
foot eight and I'm a tough day six eight
yeah six 752 now and it's INRI imitating
well the camera makes me look a little
smaller and I can't it's been over five
hundred pounds of start smoking look you
are a big guy depending on the way you
saturation so when I show up I gotta be
extra sweet it happens people like what
bulla Burra loose yeah and then you know
when I'm kind and I'll you know I'm not
making my way through doorways
yeah and I'm knocking over chit chairs
with my hips sure yet and I get into a
you know a makeup trailer and the thing
just falls over and you know you got to
be very kind yeah make up a you got to
make up for it so if that means you get
friend-zoned right away
that's fine these are the facts of life
another fact of life is put you and me
and CM Punk in a [ __ ] bowl eyebrow
and a Berlin waffle a bowl a big like a
big big bowl yeah just a big one I got
like location let's drain the Long Beach
aquarium
yeah the Sharks in sure yeah because I
wanted to fight in there or why fighting
in collide all right I'm not saying when
you finish a bowl of cereal when you eat
cereal yeah right
let's see where and what's your favorite
cereal
Captain Crunch I got Captain Crunch is
pretty good I like corn so how about I
tell you what what you're the cornflakes
CM Punk is the Captain Crunch we got a
nice bowl of that you know make sure
yeah and you got to milk you like almond
milk you probably not doing Gary I like
long ago yeah when you're just about
when you only have a couple spoonfuls
left yeah where is where where is the
Captain Crunch and the cornflakes when
it's spent at the very end of the boy I
guess lies a little bit is it on the
side yeah I guess maybe one or two
colors at the bottom there I put aside
man where's the where's the milk out of
the bottle at the bottom of the bowl
yeah point here well that's where I want
you and CM Punk throughout this
throughout this contest at the bottom
center of the bowl with me where you
can't get away and Will's a big old
shredded look a big ol this credibly
good knowing shredded and you're like oh
this isn't this is gonna be sweet
he's got that sugary side no you don't
get the show's over benign you sit
around you get that [ __ ] dry dry yeah
god that's gonna give me rub battle I'm
not talking about me right I'm not
talking about frosted mini-wheats I'm
talking about the discontinued wheat
there's any talk about they're just a
shredded red and we just read yeah when
the whole husk get a whole yeah whole
huh schematic I yeah D oh you mean one
big mahalo you gotta you gotta chop it
up yeah you'll figure mafia six lots
this is six blasts a week they did Chuck
that's right it's just obvious unshut
that we will it just look like straw
wheat pillow ah and you got a you know
how small a Captain Crunch nugget is yet
one of those not actions only one thing
I'm gonna box credit if you push and
play that right I don't care how much
milk you pour on me I'm still going to
be a shredded wheat you got to take your
spoon and mash it apart that's your
challenge so when we fight us when we
fly your problem yeah when we fight in
the UFC
yeah they're going to have the Octagon
and it's like here's the Octagon yeah
and we're they're going to it's going to
be like right from the ceiling they're
going to drop down this bowl this
decorative yeah with like cherries or
somebody you know what I said they had
to be clear and there's going to be
cherished
on a Saudi glass bowl and they're going
to slide you and you're gonna make and
then CM Punk sliding to the middle and
then I'll slide it thud and we're all in
the middle now you're ready hold on you
ready are you ready come on here's a cm
I go like this I go brother listening
we're doing over a little bit a little
bit our gun right now I understand that
he's a big kid here's the thing I know
for a fact that he's essentially what
we're essentially fighting through and I
said his respect other guy he can't hear
me was fighting on an overgrown girl but
here's why he's got zero testosterone
and here's the reason because he can do
a movie with Christina Hendricks on CNN
Miller and and like a non-american beep
pals with him right where is a great
point man yeah is even if he's married
with two kids in the house and all the
[ __ ] zosyn with a man a real man the
guy that I'm a friend I wanted my my
dog's the dog I ride with he's he's got
to be constantly and I mean 24/7 doing
whatever he can to break her walls down
and get him and get out of the fence as
you're talking [ __ ] right but since
you did your house and your non-american
I'm fighting from a cantata thread is
your aim brother coming in there and I'm
[ __ ] pop pop pop pop pop and I'm
dancing behind you and Sammy right kick
kick kick and I'm up up up up and after
a while yeah big tree comes down so
here's what I'm going to say to that as
you're explaining this to CM Punk he's
going to be looking at you he's gonna
have a serious face on you're gonna we
know you're going to be serious and he
ain't even observe you're gonna observe
that he has one ear it's a little bit
out
yeah but cauliflower and as you're
talking to him your eyes going to drift
to that ear yeah and you're going to
remember and you're going to realize
this guy's been punched in the head one
time and he has a cauliflower ear we're
doomed
we're got cauliflower
he's been punched in the head area one
time in his life and look what happened
to him and then you look across to me
and maybe it's a little bit too much for
me maybe I'm sort of reconsidering it
maybe I am that kind guy yes an actor on
set who doesn't need to test himself
this way yeah but you know what's
happening is you're looking across at my
gleaming white body my gigantic it I'm
close to me
oh no there's a single enough I'm
whoring he looks like RJ the child
veteran I'm wearing a rope like a sumo
Rope diaper oh yeah just up my ass
Yokozuna right Yokozuna oh no I'm
barefooted I have not had a pedicure in
a while my calluses yellow my told me my
pretty ashy along the lash Eon my knees
and elbows and my heels and I'm look you
look at me and as you're explaining to
see them and you're like I don't know
seems been punched one time and look at
his ear and then you look over at me and
I am weeping and yeah wills we why are
you wheat because it's just too much for
me it's all too much for me because you
don't want to be there just a sweet
[ __ ] really all just a nice guy okay
but something's happening inside of me
I'm getting it I'm getting emotional I'm
thinking about my brother pushing my
nose to my knees going meatball boy on
ball baby weight so it's an angry cry
the time I was big enough to get him
back my brother had you know wife and
kids ah yeah I can't take out his yeah
it's over I never got the retribution on
puff so you had a lot of teenage anger I
got all sorts as you put it in the dog
in the bear that's a thank you yeah you
said fat teenager syndrome yes he's got
a lot of he's all of that angst and that
anger yeah is is coiled up like a Viper
inside of his gut ready to strike
waiting for the right moment yeah and
now he's starting to tear up and you
know me because good friends and you
love me yeah and you go oh no this is
the moment here is a moment maybe I got
a storm or bill I'm about to Bob maybe
I'd like this an eyebrow it's cool we're
good man let's get out of this fish
can't go near by a drain all of a sudden
from outside the bowl you're going to
see all of the officials of the UFC
because this is different Matt they're
going to start pouring a canola oil and
corn syrup down the edges people who
didn't tell me about this sticky and
slippery no I don't know way out
and then a clock a big digital clock
over the ring starts and it says 60 and
then it goes down to 59 59 yeah it's
right it's a 60 minute match and there's
no way out of it
and then I really start falling and you
guys are super tight bro where are you
in this I need a hablar oh hey bro you
Joe are breaking this down my friends
know I'll be like that only know where
to break down three fools in a bowl but
we can't wait to watch it I feel like
yeah with Ryan Callen it's been good
knowing you CM punk suck my dick
time for you to get the [ __ ] kicked out
of you by a crying polar bear and you're
watching it here on UFC 200 and
something to look at some that's what
it's called
are you empty too hard and some harm
assaulted the song 250 towards something
we're in a ball is work you seek to earn
some we're in a ball you'll see 200 some
brought to you by on it getting the ball
getting a ball red ball
CM Punk you want to fight again [ __ ]
here's a million dollars get in the bowl
in the ball
yeah how much does a UFC those fights
the mixed martial arts place where they
have in Russia they do this where they
have games it looks like Sonic luckily
they're not they're like night gear oh I
love that
the nightmare UK yeah they're in there
in the Octagon but they're dressed is
night yeah actually [ __ ] each other
I've seen the one on one six one six
yeah other games it like [ __ ] yeah
like they tagging and else and it's
literally like oh yeah war there's 12
guys be knighted in a ring it's a chaos
that's a ground up that's amazing really
doing a field too they have mixed
martial arts guys with I have six guys
who are trained MMA guys and six guys
heating frame and they fight as teams
and and want that so when you knock your
do that you can go over a pylon right
some Russian [ __ ] yeah yeah very Russian
is they have athletic commissions in
Russia really probably don't they're not
proud ever yet fish in here yeah no
there's no [ __ ] way yeah well that's
good let's go to Russia we can do it in
Russia I'm
now do you remember the Billy Joel
concert in Moscow
no Billy Joel in Moscow okay there's a
concert I do like about 30 minutes or 30
years ago yeah grandma yeah yeah
something like that and everybody's in
the lights go out on Broadway yeah yeah
saw the Empire State let Lou yeah life
went on beyond the Palisades
they all bought Cadillacs left there
long ago we held a concert out in Russia
that's why you're Ivan bridges blue who
burned our power down drove us on the
ground we went right on with the show I
can't believe I remember that song
that's another song it's called don't
sure they have a vibe live out a live
video that lose it timing that out say
Tom Petty
no it's Miami it's Billy Joel Miami live
Miami
mm wait long I thought it was real good
the song is called just you know guys
just going on Billy Joel [ __ ] Russia
no no just go Miami Russia concert right
there double you got it you want the
song Miami live and you'll hear it are
you can do the Russia thing see says mm
Miami live why are we wide in 2017
because we put Miami live if you just do
Russia for God like a deluxe she can do
is very hot she communed with Iran still
rocking on to me you may be right now
all right - what's a little bit I felt
was great yeah Billy Joel is great I was
listening to Billy Joel not too long ago
do you guys know no he's still around
this was Robert he tried to retire him
singing I was in Russia in 1987 we were
never in it last time you were resident
all the way on your this thing I was
there when I was communist and I
remember you know well Derwin went to
worki park the russians are amazing
people I just want to say that they just
have an oppressive government terrible
thing decide whether they're uh you know
there there are people just like anybody
else but as strong
yeah the culture then they got that stug
they got that thug
and that's the problem that's the
problem is the thuggish Amin so will
this will people be able to hear this on
the podcast
I don't know look at that guy he looks
like Luke Wilson in the Royal Tenenbaums
hey if you check out Billy alright
yeah he's being way too American for the
Russians you know he really is yeah he's
really bringing him all the America oh
hey
he's like yeah rook in the role relied a
little longer
I kind of like guys dress fitted hair
but it's will versus Bryan and CM Punk
it was pretty cool back then where you
didn't have the internet or anything
there were such different cultures you
would go to Europe back then and people
would be dressed completely differently
than you were real no summit yeah most
of them had not been Victor country and
most of them didn't know how you lived
your day-to-day life and I was in Gorky
Park in 1987 and I remember they were
asking me because they didn't have blue
jeans they didn't have sneakers they
didn't get cars that we had and they
wanted to know that but we're gonna get
kicked off they wanted to know they want
to know about me all those Russians they
want to know what it was like to be an
American they had no [ __ ] idea what
happened over eyes watching Billy Joel
and I was bored and so I thought once
I'm up Russia I freaked out that's all
right lost your mind
so what else is going on nobody ever
interviews you guys guys have people you
know you're an army when I was a kid I
don't want to talk about now what you
want to know her in Australia what was
your favorite part of Australia aside
from I saw on Instagram you think world
shows you see the kangaroo though no I
didn't see that oh it's me laying down a
room bring that up Jim had a room dad
molested a kangaroo oh pretty sure is on
trend you put your hand in his bag oh
you'll see I didn't think about that
put your hand in Dale does only probably
the females help out - yes only the
females and giant pouches that email
from oh you know I'd like to hope that
we're huge was a wombat a wombats a big
weird-looking might as well have you
ever done this no I've never done that
look at how bees out of five million
eyes and he was just yeah it's a female
I think I can see her cooch she's why
yeah she's playing she's like herself
while you rub her ass you she's like a
job put your hand here
and so you can have them as pets and
they can hang out like that ah no no no
no really because you know they'll jump
up and shake your children in the face
and they'll die I just tried to get down
here with them because you see he's like
getting some Sun yeah that's I'd be a
funny video you know but what about the
big ones what about hey there in
kangaroo else no they have those big
ones Jaclyn's I think this was a
sanctuary and then there was like a
little fence and so they could come in
and out with the have they please
and the big Jaclyn's right a thick as
humans and they're like all the way in
the back Oh like we're good bro and I
caught this one slip and so that's Lima
well but you could you go in it you
could go in there with the big ones yeah
you could yeah I mean your wording it's
like a six minute minute you're laying
down on that on that you're down on that
[ __ ] dirt yeah yeah I got some us
trailer ticks after this put this one B
- that's a great that's hilarious that
video is hilarious and he's loving it
yeah the King I do business all day
[ __ ] nothing they have a big
Jacqueline so is what the Wamba I got my
shake huge The Wombats revoir Matt I
thought one that's what is that what
it's called
Jim was that thing we saw that was
laying down was like a song about his
idea yeah I think I was wrong bad is one
but it's huge white like a leg besides
of this what huge I don't want to wombat
it it's like a rodent big a little
squirrel shut up we'll look at that
thing ah [ __ ] that thing is adorable not
what it smiles though oh my god it looks
like will things doesn't look like me
anything I wake up in the morning it's
so cute P it was the size of this what
that's a giant eye let's just know
you'll bite you know animals eat the
[ __ ] out of those things
okay that's across all hunters uh not a
beauty is a crocodile donkeys really
yeah beautiful man dude got that she's
right next to that one that one I'm
worried about a bite in the faceoff I
said joy it's like a koala bear on land
it looks a lot like a koala clobbers
wrong there's right there oh there's no
very courageous I wonder if they're good
eat in trees I bet they are but you
could eat the [ __ ] out of one yeah I was
wrong then all that it's like this beats
really I was reading some stuff about
pre-agricultural Homo sapiens you want
how they they used to just burn down
parts of the the
Woods in the shrub so then they would
just go in and eat the cooked the cooked
and Cabral I'll make sense yeah it was
like a you know is just a barbecue for
them that's how they used to do it it's
not true yeah it is true so I kind of
feel like I would like to you know maybe
I could author a diet sort of a caveman
diet type thing yeah the early homo
sapien diver down land where you just
won't be good if you had some land but
it would be pretty cool any animals you
eat you just forgot [ __ ] eyeballs and
all okay there's put them in a bush I'm
burn them now maybe in a bowl no maybe
that's what this whole things about not
burning bush in a bowl oh my god you
just throw mice in their lounge in I am
now in Chum up know what if we crew
burning bushes into the bowl while we
fought no no I don't really cause them
to show us some current events
I do thank God we're almost done with
this [ __ ] hey how late was I dude sorry
I mean I got a lot of [ __ ] to do today
me too and you don't alright the first
one is what's happening right now
yeah so the GOP parts of some of the GOP
are doing a baseball game yeah and rapid
fire Virginia so gunman opened fire he
hit one of the aides one of trumps aides
Steve's SAS Co what Steve Scalise I love
playing the to the Republicans have are
they were playing a baseball game mm-hm
and this guy who came to DC to protest
according to his brother and had a
problem with Trump shot the congressman
in the hip he's the Majority Whip I
believe de Libya and he got shot in the
hip and for the people got shot and then
the cops shot him and killed it without
he was like he was 66 years old what
yeah nobody else died apparently and he
was just a [ __ ] that said you know 66
oh dude you know cigar why did he go
crazy
Perry hated Trump I was that's all he
hated Trump for a while and he was
picketing before - it's funny people
just kind of go crazy I guess in the end
they just at least his nose is nice and
symmetric yeah yeah
so weird right he does have a beautiful
smushy nose it looks like that wombat he
looks like one about human wombat Alicia
is updated glasses as well let's go get
teared yeah he looks he looks like damn
that one but he looks just like so you
shot mother please yeah he the shot a
cop's car like what yeah I love him that
happy
yeah like man you guys Chris Chris case
and then there's another shooting in San
Francisco ups name yeah this one he got
fired some right and came back and shot
people
Siana it's so brand new I don't know if
he got fired but he got dressed up went
to the you know once his work everyone's
you know they meet up people who were
shot though say he was an employee of
ups yeah yeah you he was dressed up and
everything just you know when you have
like morning meetings at work they're
all set up to go and then he just
started now he he's pretty sure he
killed two or three people right I think
five he shot five people on how many
people died I think at least two have
died I know that [ __ ] did you guys
watch the Chappelle specials yes yeah I
was very interesting I thought he made a
really interesting point about space
shuttle Challenger in 1986 same thing
having the same age as him and I
remember the them like wheeling in the
TV and I didn't go home like literally
that's what hap I'm talking with friends
going oh my god what now is we're all so
cold oh [ __ ] we were like he was alleged
so the took off and then a blue ugly I
never got everyone I was watching
because a teacher right a teacher was
was she the first civilian or she was
she was a she had been a teacher she was
her class was watching yeah and and and
and it blew up it blew up he yeah and so
all of us were watching this and and it
was just momentous really awesome
celebration and I remember it very well
because well because we were 32 years
old but hey don't don't say that so what
I was just going to say that bring it
out I remember the point that no it's
not watch that I don't know what
national tragedy can't keep me up
YouTube stuff killing cake dog yeah
about what I was going to say about it
was you know back then something really
tragic would happen and it would get you
know picked up by the news on television
now I understand the news there's of
course an agenda depending on which
news outlet we're talking about and very
few are are truly unbiased but nowadays
the the the you know the disadvantage of
having the internet the disadvantage of
not being as ignorant as we were before
is that you get this [ __ ] on a daily
basis and I just thought it was an
interesting thing that your belt said
about young people today have to take
the [ __ ] on every single day and they're
sick and tired of it and like they do
and this is the way they they came up
and now there's like you know you know
Trump which of course you know who of
course most people don't care for and
and but then you get to see [ __ ] like
this it's just negative you don't like
shot I look at my Twitter mentions every
morning I'll do the news on you I don't
know it's just negative yeah yeah yeah
it's really the worst of the worst so
you get a sense that the worlds on fire
but it kind of it's like it's not people
people from in hey what's wrong you know
and it's like you know so yeah we if
they're like yeah we're right you know
we don't like Trump and here's why and
then that don't shoot people you know
what I mean so that didn't news hard to
them you know they did it because I was
talking but you know I was always scared
to travel international forever reason
and someone sent me the statute you're
more likely to get eaten by a shark than
United die by ice yes I mean unless yes
yeah that's with your eyes but you're
right a there there the less you try
they can open shooter is there's a
famous story of the guy who was running
60 minutes my camera he owned me he was
a big executive and morally say went and
when 60 minutes was because the news
used to be not about making money right
so yes for Cronkite would come on and it
was there was sort of a civic duty to
the news absolutely when he came out and
they they tracked their ratings for the
first time in news or in 60 minute and
he that the story goes they came out and
said good news is we just destroyed the
ratings our ratings were higher than we
ever thought they would be and the bad
news is we had high ratings the other
words well there's now money in the news
but also but also people gravitate
towards those negative stores like this
reason why seanica be doing a good story
on Obama's approval rating the but if
there's a shooter
there's got the Raisa yeah yeah the
other problem of news that I think in
Washington Post the New York Times in
many ways are basically mouthpieces for
the Democratic Party and the progressive
liberal party of the Jim yeah and ends
Fox's a mouthpiece for the Republican
Party and it's very hard to find sort of
really unbiased news the BBC still does
a good job home girl megyn kelly she did
the interview with your boy that
conspiracy yeah Howard Jones and in what
do you mean your boy that's your boy
Hawk I don't like it's funny convolve a
so you know they're going babies they're
digging they're putting people in bowls
and then he's I gotta fight I was just
kidding I'm playing a character who does
the Sandy Hook killed you know how he's
like I was all gimme a basket okay well
parents who lashed out at me and tell
you like what the [ __ ] you do it sent a
picture their daughter who died didn't
you bring into light they got yes yes
then he and he and she goes he said it
was a hoax and they were all that all
his followers all these people were
harassing and still harass those poor
parents well she goes you know it's my
job bringing light to this type of
character and she got roasted yeah
they're trying to pull the ad I think it
runs to mana call people up asking for
her to get fired I really I think that's
extreme italics giant phenomenon he's a
phenomenon and I don't think a good one
he's not that big of phenomena we saw
that term around putting you know I mean
a lot of people listen to him is what I
mean no idea I was watching numbers on
it like people you know he has two
hundred seven thousand followers on
Twitter but why he's maybe 300 got sixty
million downloads I'm crazy enough okay
it was a lot of this is - what's this -
Infowars though is a lot of people
listen to it you know I don't know I'd
like to see the numbers - I spear see
Suri stuff and all that it's not as big
as you think I work around I know Eddie
and run away like that but I think I
think once a phenomenon like it's a real
issue I don't for the majority the
majority people are pretty educated not
that I believe you I believe in I think
it makes a lot of noise yeah it makes
noise in all different also he's been to
an extent be validated by President
Trump yes and so that there's a yeah so
all the Saudis up for the face of a an
Sonia bunch at six hundred forty two
thousand
uh follows followers not that much
that's not that's not that's not that
much yes not like it's got allowed
that's the amount of followers you had
you would have if you just would stop
being a [ __ ] team up with CM Punk and
quite shy yeah yeah get some eyes on you
now anyway yeah a little yeah an idiot I
thought I got an existing uh but a lot
of sponsors also pulled like that
interview they're like we're out man
that's a ton of it that's a good now
Alex Jones though but right like he
doesn't want me mate the mainstream meet
up it's all [ __ ] and all that stuff
about Alex Jones yeah and then history
media you can all [ __ ] and they do we
always come here it's a little bit over
no yeah it's it's a rather than Statler
from from Vermont from Muppets it's like
some kind of torture and then you add
some so-called to have to watch this to
have to watch the show to which it's why
do we always come here what I just we'll
never know yeah and then you pet it's
like so I'm kind of torch that's exactly
what it Waldorf and Sattler and some
clothes off and finish the couch was a
feel that about about pretty say good
night till it [ __ ] a lot but I wanted
to hear what you're doing you getting
started because you're saying I'm do you
thanks Noel shows can help you although
all the most emotional sensation is it
okay what we call our Muppet Show
Oh what were you saying I was saying
house Alex Jones like anti like media
and all that stuff yeah but then he does
he's in a run except for all he did this
interview right because it gives him he
gives them you know validation yeah but
now he's like all they should pull that
interview know that you know what they
edit that and that's not was trying to
say
that's the corporate media for it but
here's what effect probably gained via
now you're playing a game well you hold
up you said you're playing a character
now you go on this big helping hand
radio and show and now you and now
you're like oh that's not me experience
what the [ __ ] rain is selling out yeah
satisfy these people but as soon as I go
oh let's do the show he jumps in there
yeah not only you log on tomorrow I came
up with a whole came up with the Sandy
Hook massacre the it was it was a staged
thing right so the kids were actors
where they all go and the parents were
actors where'd they all go
it's [ __ ] you know and those parents
have been harassed by dumb morons what
if now Brian what if you were watching
you started youtubing footage of the
horrible massacre and the the children
being taken away from it and you
recognized one of the parents and it was
a big guy well it looked like a ballet
dancer used to go to theater school with
no and that's what he was doing for now
but he's one of those actors and I would
ask Jones's right wouldn't that be a
[ __ ] trip I worried who you fight you
in that ball that happened you want to
fight me in a bowl well that didn't
happen but we got a fight what else you
got gin okay there Floyd Mayweather a
team you know how they requested August
26 for the date of a possible fight with
McGregor they retracted it when did you
see this thing because I just saw got
approved I thought I decided Nevada
invision tell us today because what I
saw is Nevada Commission approves
Mayweather
Conor let's check but you know there's a
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on out
there yeah I make a call right now there
you go things that we're gonna happen oh
it's happening what are they gonna do
what's is going to be a boxing fight is
it going to be a boxing match boxing
match yeah it's gonna be boxing
straight-up boxing
yeah this isn't NSAC approved it oops I
know you don't that's that is not it
yeah this is where yes they approved it
26 Wow well the Commission approved it
but it doesn't mean there's a deal on
the table right no so in order for the
deal to it rating to happening up there
it has to be approved so I'd say huge
step that's a huge step because you have
a guy with no prior professional boxing
experience against a guy who's one of
the Great's of all time
so this was one of the big ko so that
the Commission will not usually approve
stuff like that one when you're that
mismatched this would this was a big huh
says it's still unclear if it's Floyd
Mayweather vs Conor McGregor but who
knows that's the date that they're
looking at looking at so I don't think
you have an August I think it's gonna
happen I think September October I think
that what we should do just to cover our
nuts is organize for our August 26th
yeah fish bowl
to get a fish bowl in this room you
already have the studio I'll schedule a
small area yes we want to be we want to
be close and tight to each other now you
got the cameras you guys know everyone
you need to know we mix martial arts to
get this thing out there a good point
guard our own Federation obviously I
don't think to be an obvious dive a
that's too soon I know they approved it
which is cool but it's not enough time
for the magnitude this fight what else
you get you all right I think it
happened did you hear about the money
and come on hearing from my sources
crazy mind you you don't you have no
idea be about the 100 a hundred million
dot each yeah what yeah yeah for them
whatever
so this boxer they're gonna make that
much money earner Daniel Franco he got
knocked out and he got put into a
medically induced coma and I'll show you
the knockout here oh I know is he dead
oh no rewind up for me oh boy scares me
oh and this is the guy right here 25
years old and he's in the hospital now
innit medically induced coma and he has
like some brain surgeries that he's
going to be going through cause it's
bleeding in the brain
oh man what does that be just an ankle
he's got caught like that and today that
young is [ __ ] brain no I'm saying no
he this is a precondition like this
it's a freak accidents like because the
guy hits like Mike Tyson has nothing to
do that this guy's a precondition
something wrong with his brain
guys a musicians are like in their
fighting well they don't see it like you
get breaks can me it depends
yeah but that has nothing to do with it
looks like John that's not to punch that
something going on oh yeah well look
[ __ ] no just a right hand
what's going on Brooke Hogan is hit the
right I need help what's going on there
what she need help with we're [ __ ] see
the far right yeah Brooke Hogan maybe
you usually know we'll all [ __ ] know by
that my god I know Brooke is in the news
brother
she lost her dog oh god I can't make it
happen
what else y'all goin away dude it's Trey
and it's going to come back soon as we
get it on TMZ dude that way everyone
will know about it brother
check this out in China I'll just play
it super quick Chinese steak eats a
mouse an air conditioner ah everybody
you do back oh oh oh he'll make his own
[ __ ] oh here's what you need to YouTube
Chinese snake eats a mouse in an air
conditioner looks like it almost the
whole player playing it
oh I'll make a call right now my hands
make up it's a fake thing
hey bro oh he's trying to meltdown oh no
we gotta wrap this up because he's
melting with one more June you got it oh
there's no good one Daria is good okay
hey I'd like to remind everybody too
that recently Bryan Callen came and sat
in on ten minute podcast of course a
podcast of Brian
helped to create helped to create yeah I
came up with it whatever and very soon
if you go and subscribe to me to podcast
on iTunes and whatever fellow 10min pod
on the thing is Twitter and stuff Brian
and my good pal the aforementioned Chad
Kultgen were interviewed by the real
Robert De Niro and Al pitrelli and out a
bit and it was very nice to hang out a
bit know Robert De Niro and Al Pacino
stop by the studio that was wild check
out that show probably next week yeah
that was very very interesting what was
your takeaway from talking to it was a
leak low number two of my acting heroes
yeah through the people that I got must
have been a very interesting interview
it was wild uh
DeNiro is kind of a more quiet you don't
have a clip yeah yeah let's play let's
play a little clip we'll go out on this
yeah should we play a little clip of De
Niro and Pacino interviewing you yeah
we'll just go out on this oh boy
water to a magic show it's been Bryan
Callen tell me about the fire in the kid
ah bugs up upon people what's that
you've got a kid I dunno Bobby he's got
a podcast yeah what's called called the
fighter in the kid I don't listen to
podcast what I call it that I think it's
because I used to I used to put them on
on iPods now so it's just a fun play on
the word broadcast that means everything
both yeah yeah yeah we get a lot of
reasons often talk a lot man listen
honor beauty was an honor dude and I and
that's not every podcast you next week
it'll be I think they I think they're
going to air that one next we have to
beat ball I think that he's really hard
that well you know that's the fun thing
about the show is you have all sorts of
people can play another clip you
you fight no no that's my box I'm a
fighter I do some boxing no soup flavor
I'm very kind of cereal
I'm sorry record cereal I ball boy
mine's Froot Loops yeah I like boring
pebbles that's the same thing Bobby yeah
a different shape yeah
what is a milk what does a milk go at
the end of the ball when you're done
eating what does it call are you tight
you asking me that
yeah he's asking you what influence
cereal I've imagined to the bottom
bottom middle yeah you're going to fight
CM Punk me and will sasso
what an amazing thing that you guys
laughs wow that is a really drum rolling
something there into this fight yeah
well well we want to thank you for
coming on that podcast best man yeah I
love coming here yeah grab a meal listen
you're great do it use you as is the
podcast goes on you start to implode a
little bit you know and I'm glad we're
getting it now he's used to ten minutes
I'm only a minute cuz you anywhere over
ten minutes on the Google blue yeah what
am I going to talk about yeah a little I
do crash they use my energy goes down
yeah while it out here out of the room
Chuck I start talking about willy-nilly
[ __ ] I start saying I say really
interesting podcast stuff like this you
can see much no missile yeah yeah don't
talk about stuff that's already some
right right create something on our own
you want to go eat it on one who stood
yeah I'll eat something you guys like
carbs that's got a juice that and you
still I like carbs as long as they're in
the form of leafy green vegetables not
carbs I'm talking about bread let's eat
some bread I got to lose here I'm gonna
make it I'm gonna make a I'm gonna make
a promise to your to your listeners the
next time I come here I will be what's a
good way for me will you looking to lose
some weight I am looking to lose some
[ __ ] weight okay let's say them a
little big say thirty pounds that yeah I
want to see you 50 pounds lighter
Jesus next time I'm here I'll be
50 pounds lighter much boom Cydia down I
hope you guys will you my yeah in three
and a half years okay I've done right
now I got to go
I read an order to go I weigh 675 pounds
it's always awesome being on a fight of
the kids and a man of Fighters again no
pay where do I go and we listen is Joe
it's a man the funnel to yourself at
home bana fatih and city yourself one of
the fans for how this is the budget and
the man route